[موسيقى]
كيف دفننا مسرحيه تتناول الصراع بين
المثقف والسلطه وتستحضر عهد يوسف ستالين
الاقصى خلال حقبه الاتحاد السوفيتي
المسرحيه منع عرضها في غالبيه المدن
الروسيه باستثنائي هذا المسرح في موسكو لا
يزال يقاوم المعه وربما
بوسي
سكر
[موسيقى]
الكاتب كان من اوائل الشخصيات العامه في
البلاد التي انتقدت بشده الحرب في
اوكرانيا
ومثله اخرون من كتاب ومسرحيين ومثقفين
منهم من غدر البلاد وجميعهم غادرت اعمالهم
او اسمائهم رفوف المكتبات والمسارحات ودور
السينما
العلاقه بين الثقافه ومراكز الحكم بالتوتر
واليوم نرى جوله جديده لتلك المواجهه
وفيها لا يمكن للثقافه ان تنتصر الان بل
ان النصر سيكون في المستقبل
[موسيقى]
مجموعه من النواب تطلق على نفسها اسم
مجموعه جراد اخذت على عتيقها وضع قائمه
سوداء غير رسميه باسماء مثقفين وفنانين
وادباء قيموا بناء على موقفهم من الحرب في
اوكرانيا
القوائم غير ملزمه ولا يتم تبنيها او
التعامل معها كتشريعات من المجلس نفسه
هؤلاء النواب يرون ان هذه الخطوه لا ترقى
الى ما يسمونه الحرب الثقافيه التي يشنها
الغرب على رموز الادب والثقافه الروسيه
كريستيانو
مقابل المال الاجنبي لذا لابد من تحرير
ثقافه الروسيه من امثالهم لتستعد ثقافتنا
مكانتها التاريخيه الرفيعه القائمه منذ
الف عام
هي تنقضات في روسيا على طول شارع اوكرانيا
ترافقنا شخصيه من الجانب الاخر للحدود
الثقافيه في اوكرانيا وصاحب مقوله الجسر
يتلالا التي استخدمها الرئيس الاوكراني
عند استهدافه جسر القرن
في اوكرانيا الجغرافيا والايديولوجيا
لتقتحم مساحات الادب والثقافه هناك تمنع
مسرحيه وهناك في اوروبا يمنع ذا الصيف
واقرانه الا انه فصول المشهد الاوسع لم
يسد الستار عنها بعد بانتظار المشهد
الاخير بين الحرب والسلام
خضر الجزيره موسكو